pour aider les jeunes restent pas ici
puis sont pas intéressés par la pêche et
émissions ainsi difficile aussi quand on
pêche au filet 15 à 18 heures par jour
même vainqueur des x 5 séances et sert
pas seulement à peu près aux alentours
de lyon si je m'engage à voir du monde
21 18 21 lots que peuvent avoir les
jeunes sont plus intelligents notre côté
cela que ils vont plus ce décor un peu
aussi quand un étrange on va en finir et
j'ai une hauteur d'un mètre pendant 10
ans du site
je demande que l'espace
s'y trouvaient c'est sur la gaspésie vos
passions pour remplacer mon temps dans
toutes mes vieux et reste l'un des vieux
des fois sont trop vieux les jeunes
mariés maya imaginez vous une journée
j'avais choix dans le flou
j'avais deux tranches de pain je le
prenais soin pour déjeuner ou soit plus
mon dîner à l'usiné parce qu'au début on
est quand même un laps de temps sans
avoir deux pays
c'était démoralisant je ne sais que ce
que je vis tout seul
à lviv mais par contre seuls à le dire
non par dallas grâce à prokom c'était
des gens paresseux mais ces points
communs dans l usine de cet arrêt on
travaille fort on travaille dur commence
à se servir du matin on finit à 80000
soir et puis on est debout toute la
journée les premiers temps les poignées
venant voler les becs sa rente pu
oublier ceux ci pour manuel je veux
qu'elle gouvernement harper comprennent
que nous les gaspésiens on n'est pas des
paresseux on n'a pas peur de travailler
mais craque a plus d'emploi lengagne a
raté nous punir karting trek avec
l'asthme ou voulez vous qu'on prenne le
poisson et patrons nous garderons pour
regarder la mer
ce qui nous inquiète c'est que nos
travailleurs vont se trouver des emplois
à l'extérieur chez un autre employeur
ait qui ne reviennent pas en avril alors
c'est ce qui nous inquiète le plus que
légères qu'elles on ne donnait de la
formation vont devoir nous quitter c'est
difficile de trouver les nouveaux
candidats
surtout je vous dirais les candidats au
niveau mécanicien technicien dé contre
oman dans mes gens avec un profit plus
spécialisés il ya de moins en moins de
main d'oeuvre disponible je me suis vu
souvent embarqués dans mon champ qui
garde je m'envole pointé ce bout du quai
puis la musique au beau fixe en braille
sais c'est quoi que je fais comment que
je fais payer mais chante pas mais ne
peut pas travailler pourquoi pas vous
rappeler table dans le bayou donc là
c'est un moins de 1100 pas peur alors
qu'elle avait quand même parce pire mais
le plus qu'à vie puisqu'elle prendra
naissance ou papa pourquoi papa papa
travaille willis ou bleu blanc et le
blanc est plein et trois parmi eux pour
mais ce qui est pas facile dans fond
c'est justement parce que moi j'ai
manqué de sarre avec l'assurance chômage
c'est ce qui l'a obligé à faire les
chantiers le fait qu'ils lui pas c'est
parce que c'est moi qui punit par
l'assurance chômage
c'est que papa doit combler pour ce que
moi j'ai perdu
la réforme de l'assurance emploi
on remarque que les problèmes de santé
mentale ont énormément augmenté
ça a amené beaucoup d'anxiété chez les
gens beaucoup de rupture au niveau des
couples l'écho prestance a amené aussi
beaucoup de violence conjugale ce qu'on
voit aussi des troubles anxieux chez les
jeunes la 6 ans 7 ans 8 ans dans un très
beau george
parce que les parents sont dépassés
parce que les familles sont souvent
séparés parce que les conjoints doivent
partir travailler à l'extérieur donc on
ne retrouve souvent des mamans
monoparentales avec les enfants au lion
toute la charge avec eux et la situation
économique est très difficile donc nous
on se voit régulièrement donné des bons
alimentaires aux gens pour essayer de
subvenir à leurs besoins
on a un très haut taux de suicides qui
est souvent reliés au travail
et c'est très difficile au niveau de la
population